right back the line against the heer line to start
this one it's underway glad to have you with us on
a Saturday Tellis Flames hockey on sportset here's
jper Brad in front trying to JB one on goal it was
knocked away and scooped up by Coleman who brings
it out of his own Zone gain Center lifts the puck
in bounces wide of Van loose side of the goal
he'll bat it back to the end boards Flames are
on it though here's hanen looking for a lane
there's a shot that goes just one TANF picks
it up plays it all the way around for his partner
Hanan pinching down the boards bumps it back to
the point to Coleman Coleman tries a shot bounces
right over to bman Turning Coleman bit of a lane
and a shot on goal turned away by vanich stopped
the rebound to flames clear the zone to Center
Ice bounces free right to Miller who carries
back in to FY long shot wolf got a piece of
that steer It Wide bapon behind the that took a
bump down low from seen ther Devils have chance
to work it out as holla feeds it ahead down the
left side carried in by Hughes with some speed
and up Sav by wolf on that Hughes Jack that is
gets a nice chance on he follows up feeds it
across Hugh puts it in FL break it up long pass
here's B with a shot off the glove of V into
the corner he's going to get a shot from well
out van just gets a piece of that considering
the devils are so good on the power play might
have something to do it the afternoon we will
see if this power play gets rolling here's
Hughes breaking through sto by wol snag that
one team o Meer plays it across bouncing mck
Mercer C Coral it and the Flames get it out
and here's a chance shorthanded and finally
Sharon goic able to get it has weer in front
scor on the back what a play by Sharon goic
a shorthanded goal makes it one nothing count
watch this play along the boards here's Coleman
gets it to him now there's a oneon-one battle
right there between he and poot and he pulls
away goes back in and roofs it beautiful goal
with 18 seconds left in the first but that is
a prime example of what the Flames want from
Sharon goic consecutive short-handed goals was
in one game back in 2018 29th against Vancouver
Curry two is underway here's Anderson working
it in front colan hit a leg oh it's somehow
stayed out I think van might have got a piece
of that chance by hubero and what a great play
Here by weager he's going to try and throw it
across to Coleman I believe and it goes right
to Rasmus and he that's what he loves to do join
the rush here's the empty net and he throws it
right through the grease let's take a look it
goes off eer at first oh yeah Miller puts it
down low for heer push to the boards by tanv
heer stays in the battle got it in front and
brat stopped by wolf Coleman gets the puck
to the line not out brat with a Chance again
feeds it over heer with a shot SC over the
glove of wol turnover at the line with the
Flames looked like they would be able to get
out of the zone and it winds up being a tie
game right behind the net watch tanv
come in T of is so good at pinning
people against supports he sure spins away
gets it in front to Bratt then they track
down the puck there's a turn over at
the Blue Line Coleman can't get it
out brat back to heer and he goes High
short side that is a beautifully play
shot and it's one nothing Jack Hughes pressure
knocked down by Zer leager gets it up Zer trying
to settle it down to two-on one with goich
tumbling clck Sharon goich shoots stopped by
Van play back to the line Gilbert shoots off
the post ring it off the iron when you look
at this play they just lofted into the
neutral zone Zer gets it and there's a
first good chance from Sharon goit now watch
Gilbert from the point Lazar back the other
way Zer hassles Lazar sticks with it feeds
it around Marino bumps it back shot of the
traffic and chipped off the post I think
Lazar might have deflected that off the
iron game Devils almost Take the Lead Lazar
with the tip goalie's best friend keeps it
1-1 he sure who has the Jersey goal feeds it
ahead brat chips it across now it's worked in by
palot Miller joins the rush heer trailing returned
there gets right in front got a weak shot away W
down trying to cover up pinballs in ricocheted off
traffic in front and it's a 2-1 Jersey lead some
chaos around the calary creas and somehow that
winds up of the net the puck there it is to brat
now let's just or Pilot excuse me let's see what
happens here when the puck goes behind the net
wolf is kind of knocked out of position Coleman
throws it in front and it goes right off the shin
pad I believe of brat let's take a look at this
again Watch Dustin wolf he's going to get pushed
out of position with the feet of heer I wonder if
the Flames are going to challenge that after video
review the actions of the Cy player propelled the
New Jersey player into the goal therefore we have
so that was the question I had they feel he was
taken down and not just the argument that they
make Jack Hughes shot blocked L gotten the way
Puck stays in the zone jper brat feeds it over
Jack Hughes lets it fly off the post and the puck
Ricochet is out of play his brother Jack and watch
that when he rips it right off the crossbar
tan trying to do his best as he always does
trying Marino
again 9 minutes into period three steered in
wol out to play it to Hanan out of his reach
though picked off by Holt pass in front
they score another turnover leads to a
goal and it's Teo Meyer putting it in to make
it 3 to one Jersey let's take a look at this
wolf with the pass and it's a bad pass there's
Holtz throwing through and not sure let's take
another look Dylan duet throws his head back
as though it might be off him no I think it is
meer what do you think it went off T at first
and then off es let's see here we can goes on
right so that'll be holz's goal I yes his I I
wondered cuz as soon as the puck went in I saw
the reaction after the replay Kelly you point it
out with a good ey no not that I have a good eye
but here's a chance now for hubo right in STO by
vanich good pass by Coleman to send hubero in on
the back hand cut it to one good look here
for hubero vanich makes his 21st save puck
back to the line tumbles out as Hanahan had
to back off Anderson turning from Lazar gets
to Center in over the line Anderson dropped
it off there's a shot score kry top CH what
game watch this played by Rus Anderson from his
own Z Wheels right through the neutral zone weaves
in gives a puck to cadri from a sharp angle CAD
beats van gives a flame plenty of life with over
for five minutes to go Ras Anderson taking
charge right there played all the way around
Hanan trying to get there chips the puck down low
slides free heer has it shoots for the empty net
scores 190 footer for ni heser seals it for our
jersey with 37 points seven to go and then the
Puck Noah Hanan comes in there seing thers in
there battling the puck comes loose and look how
everybody's backing up so it gives plenty of time
for heer to settle this down without even looking
so they've shown a lot of character this season
as Jersey has won now six of its last seven and
they did it with a two goal second added to that
lead and then put the empty net home to ster 42